well happy saint patty's day  celebration of  saint patrick  who we all know and love so well yeah  saint patrick uh driving out snakes he  did the thing with the snakes and uh  you know and then people were like  that's cool let's get hammered let's get  hammered about it  yeah yeah but then they were like where  do our [ __ ] snakes go  [ __ ] are they part of the ecosystem they  work god damn it  but no snakes there in ireland as is the  case with um hawaii you know about yes  you know about this they got like one  species of snake which is more like a  worm  so  [Laughter]  a worm is just a snake that is like way  more lame  right you know what i mean it's like  it's like  like all worms want to be snakes you  know what i mean like their words like  when i grow up i'm definitely gonna be a  snake dude i know i can make this hat  doesn't work that way yeah walter it  does not work that way wait hold on  walter is that your fist your butt